hey guys I'm Lisa from the score eSports
in the first week of the 2017 summer
split we saw pros like hooni and someday
play Lucian in the top lane and it
actually worked out in their favor on
the one-on-one yet and really be that
good pulling is out oh that's dog though
he's going to kind of lean go to
platform crazy I just now notice this
well Kobe Sunday the man you'd be
dashing in right now gunning these guys
down right next to their own Nexus 428
farm in 35 minutes that is some kind of
a work of art in honor of the
unconventional top lane pick we're
counting down the top 10 best solution
plays in League of Legends history
coming in at number 10 is well turtle
double kill against lmq which he managed
to land while retreating from a
teamfight just do whatever he wants
about crowd control for Team solomid has
been very big without Cataclysm they are
losing this one it's pure chaos AK
remain even jumps in the silly plasters
forward to the fight while turtle can
put out big damage but any two three
more he gets a tough uphill wild turtle
with the Aqua comes out huge but still
he's already class robbing the ninth
spot on our list is SS double kill in
the bot lane while on CLG taking down
high and lemonnation crowd control that
he has denied from the fight high is low
and mana double if knows it that is not
the first time he's a straight into
enemies Douglas wants two kills and he
knows you could get it this time it
works in this fight was all about ad
carry positioning I'm a cutie pies
insane mechanics Ellucian against team
coast feels a spot on our list Rick we
have saffice August I was also visit
damage but with fusions off on the side
somewhere next victim is most likely
going to be times what they're trying to
run him down
cutie pie cutie pies got one cutie pies
life skills is it meant detectives need
to repel that's a guy who gets it all
just shut up
back with the truffle cutie-pie John
huge quick attack coming in at number
seven is banks pentakill against fnatic
at MSI 2015 pop are they going to go oh
who needs in quite get to bang female
wolf comes back of the head nepal rice
gravy Kaiser comes down reign over for
any of the back lines of dingy with a
big absolute zero Morin is huge
literally because that wild growth
Hootie manages the catch maker with his
ultras of Baker vacua fanatic in big
trouble double Gilbert Vega ready make
it a triple gel and now Kate Villa calm
just pick up
[Applause]
can they ended right now dealing the
sixth spot is Samsung Galaxy White's imp
and his ability to land a double kill
but still escape to safety show himself
so kind of push it out there coming into
a thick foliage decelerate are they
gonna finish about one for also thankful
attorney
there is it going aggressive he gets the
kill on Trixie can take on it since
gates if tasting amazing a miracle
superhuman kiting Aleutian against rock
tiger that world comes in fist on our
list so you can see the little hole just
a real off with a huge play fights up
with a polarized and a miracle cutting
it out but he's actually going to get
out of the way yet talk about there's
some more get a pump a miracle to fight
against disease Saturday Gary you try to
get some little place IRA oh you're
kidding me that's exactly what they gave
to
they might have an offering a food court
again and coming in fourth is for
Gibbons Mathis pentakill against KMP
during the LCS promotion qualifier back
in 2014 incident Jacob cake straight
away from that one and the wolves are
ripping up the pieces here two kills
already blows to them for forgiving and
he continued soon there's a ball can he
get the Penta he flashes in front and
there is a persica
coming down for forgiving the third spot
goes to SKT bang and his surprise
appearance in the top lane during a team
fight against CJ entus
oh my god SK Telecom can't they turn it
round faker still alive things all comes
in just quite a bit Baker managed to get
out of it with a flash now Lauren just
brawling with everyone wolf looking for
opportunities as well to think he came
back guys there's a knock upon the paint
oh they take down space sighs Russell
back up here comes bang gets in the back
oh man loosen you go on him in your back
line shy getting low
nice natural charge from Koko but
ambitions still taken out by Baker bang
continuing to chase gets the double low
health he's going to back away
coming in second is endlessness
pentakill against snaky sports it really
was a parade of endless kill
because he the turret but that was
actually a really nice disengage at a
snake and this shows their coordination
is returning and ours once again looking
for it
teleport coming in the backline yeah
flooded looking for a kill this could be
a fight here plunger who's going to lock
down he does find endless but he gets
altered instantly play easy hood he is
almost going to go down but elegance a
massive form and Paul Chryst Aldo who
opted up on the other side by long and
fadres man who looks their specs to you
with a package would be easy who knew
pops the Aussie endless massive
positioning over the side as they
finally take down the Bromberg binky go
massive that's a Quadra endless get
himself a pentakill and what good
positioning out of the ad carry our
number one lucien play is none other
than double live game-changing team
fights against c9 during the 2016 summer
final Judy gold Menaka be my captain yes
they do by old frost is down booth is
gonna trade in pipe as well though
former before no supports alive no
guardian angel for me do swear as TSM
still have to into your Hall we resolve
sub couple now can they have the
follow-up damage a couple stuns come in
they've got the exit and they shut us
down with a 1600 damage critical double
low medius another knock of Tracy's life
but it's down below get your da
definitely all kill everybody
safe country if that goes down Haysbert
ESL SS turns around the fight staying
alive so much bacon by this time and he
takes over and these death timers are
massive the wave they have in the farm
site and fight be able to end the
steering and there you have it those are
our picks for the top 10 best Lucien
plays in legal legends history do you
agree or disagree with our list let us
know in the comments below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button